I'm actually pregnant are you right now
yeah is this exclusive Ian Somerhalder
joking about being pregnant isn't such a
stretch now the actor and his wife Nikki
Reed are expecting their first child and
I'm really excited
both Nikki and Ian shared this sweet
photo to Instagram on Thursday the
former Vampire Diaries star kissing his
wife's baby bump
Nikki wrote quote how is it possible to
love someone so much already
all I know for sure is it's the
strongest feeling I've ever felt can't
wait to meet you love your parents the
bear who celebrated their second wedding
anniversary last week have been itching
to become parents for a while
here's what Ian told et in 2015 do you
want to be a dad oh hell yes absolutely
you know it's all about practice it's
not practice makes perfect it's perfect
practice it's just the most incredible
thing to be happy and secure in
something and it's a pretty crazy time
and place to bring a child into this
turbulent insane world but I really
can't wait to do it and really just love
it
you
[Music]